hey hey hey blooper time [ __ ] ha ha
I shouldn't have crested you that was
wrong
Oh what is going on YouTube now as you
guys may already know I think this
two-part series called Nikes just do it
kidding hey it was the best Korean Nike
commercial ever
and I still stand by that because it's
this year so if you guys are wondering
well why did you do it in Korean is
because Cunningham you say just do it
it's kind of like the comedic thing that
it's funny as [ __ ] to a lot of creepy
bullet but you know if you're not Korean
it I don't know still should be funny
[ __ ] you but before we start getting to
the bloopers I want to go ahead and
think cafe Mac out of Koreatown Los
Angeles for letting us use that location
thank you guys love you very much and go
check them out you know the cool spot to
chill get drinks relax and do some work
y'all II might even catch me there I'm
not a mom but yeah as this video got
really really weird especially that ass
pimple situation there my homegirl giddy
Rafik actually did that [ __ ] for me
enough that [ __ ] was [ __ ] nasty here
but yes I had a dope time doing this and
there's a lot of cut footage in there
actually there's a lot of fans that came
out to be a part of the video but we
didn't put it in because did it come out
the way that I wanted to but it's still
kind of funny so you got to see it here
so uh enjoy the bloopers my friends pop
you
hi smoke probably - ready
yeah you're right stop recording the
time I do like this like this or like
this we want dog tell us you wanna guys
oh okay so it looks like that look at it
for a pit ball takes a
hmm boy though
dick